if indeed we are to lead others and step
outside our own industry how do we
innovate that how do we do that
so let's think about Innovation
Innovation for two seconds
for millennia
Innovation predominantly meant Hardware
right
I made a bit of printing press now the
printing press that we have today is
basically the same thing that Gutenberg
did it's a thing that goes like this it
goes fast or sure but it's basically the
same thing right the airplane is
basically the same physics right it's
100 the same physics
um but for for for for for many many
many years Innovation meant hardware and
Hardware is very expensive which is why
the only uh organizations that could
innovate were governments and large
companies right because you could afford
to
the computer and the internet completely
changed that
um the the invention of the personal
computer and Steve Wozniak one of the
founders of Apple talked about this he
says I imagine a day in which an
individual could compete against a
corporation the computer allows that
where literally one person can compete
against a company that's incredible
and the speed at which innovation can
happen because innovation in the
hardware model is slow and expensive in
the software model it's fast and cheap
right so think of your iPhone
the hardware is very expensive it's over
a thousand dollars which is insane and
when they release it it actually has
software on it that is imperfect and
they know it's imperfect but they give
it to you anyway and then very quickly
they start fixing it and the patches
start coming out right and sometimes
it's minor you don't even see the
difference and sometimes it's major you
get a major overhaul and eventually the
software gets too big
that the hardware can no longer contain
it and then you have to buy a new piece
of expensive Hardware
and this is the model that old companies
have to learn to embrace
and if you look at the companies that
are dominating right now whether it's
Netflix it's still big it's it's habits
issues but it's still big Netflix which
reinvented film and television Tesla
which is Reinventing cars Amazon which
is Reinventing uh uh retail
they're all new companies they're all
Facebook Google Tick Tock they're all
data companies the old style of big
innovation those companies aren't the
biggest companies anymore they used to
be but they're not the biggest companies
anymore it's data and it's because of
their speed at which they can make
change
and so the companies that are struggling
are the companies that are trying to
Simply add data to their Hardware model
so if we add a flat screen TV to our car
we're Innovative no no no Tesla built an
iPhone if
Tesla built an iPhone on Wheels what
makes that car remarkable is not that
it's an electric car it's that my 2002
Tesla and my friends 2019 Tesla do the
exact same things because the car can
update itself
we have all the same features it's not
the old way where yeah I don't have
those features I have the the I have
last year's model
right that's gone